today as you were saying I'm going to be
talking about WebSockets and we're gonna
be talking about it from sort of a
beginners standpoint so someone who's
never actually really used it more has
sort of like heard of what WebSocket is
but has never actually gone to the
effort of actually using it in one of
their projects so a bit about me I'm
doing music that's my name
I'm a full-time associate developer at
Weiss tech currently I study at UTS
doing the vit co-op scholarship so
that's the Bachelor of information
technology I spoke at PyCon last year
something you might have been at my talk
and I did a bit of data science work at
the ANU last year as well and so I'm 18
years old and I'm obviously from
Canberra and have recently moved up here
to study and to give you guys a bit of
structure about what we're going to be
going through today we're gonna sort of
start off with a basic low level
understanding of some of the protocols
which we're gonna be talking about today
sort of to get an idea of where
everything sits in the whole IT world
we're going to go over some of the use
cases and the applications which you
might find using WebSockets and I'm
gonna go over some of the previous
technologies which might be used in
place of WebSockets since it's still
quite relatively new and we'll go a bit
about the browser support and the
characteristics of WebSockets as a
protocol and how fast it is in
comparison to other implementations and
of course what you're here for is the
Python aspect of it so we're going to go
over how Python has a role to play with
it and how easy it is to do things with
WebSockets with Python and just a quick
note at the end we're going to go
quickly over how deploying WebSockets
works over the web so to get into it
we're gonna start off with a pretty
contrived example and so anyone who's
done any sort of networking or taking
any networking courses would have seen
something similar to this you probably
would have seen something called the OSI
networking layers so this is the
Internet Protocol suite and this is sort
of just to get an idea of where
everything sits relative to each other
so I'm gonna start from the bottom
you'll see the transport layer so these
are things which
define the way that data packets are
transferred over the web right so these
are things such as TCP and UDP and so
TCP guarantees that any packet they send
over the web will reach his destination
in the same order which there was sent
right and it does this by acknowledging
the packet once it's reached its
destination so say I want to send a
packet to a web server TCP guarantees
that all of my packets will get there
and I want to mention that UDP the less
important one to TCP is a bit more
careless and it doesn't really care
about this guarantee of order and it's
generally used for things like streaming
video data where we don't care if we
lose some of the packets on the way and
so TCP is sort of the underlying
transport layer behind a lot of the
things I'm going to be talking about
today and so then you move up to the
next stage which is the internet layer
so this is things like ipv4 and ipv6
which define the addresses which packets
are sent right so everyone has an IP
address you've probably heard of this in
any regards it's it's pretty much where
data is sent on the web and so we then
get to the application layer which is
sort of a top-level layer and this is
where HTTP web sockets and the rest of
them all sit this is the sort of stuff
that you guys might interface with when
actually developing things now again I
want to admit that this is a very
contrived example so take this layers in
with a like a grain of salt
I would suggest if you want to do
further reading into where everything
sits to either Google the OSI layer
model or just looking into any
networking courses that you can now I'm
in a sort of basic just to get one sort
of up to speed and you probably all know
what HTTP is but for those that don't
it's pretty much this request model
where a client sends a request to a
server the server then processes that
request and then responds with like
anything so right we it could be a HTML
page it could be anything and so
generally you type in a URL the client
is that browser that sends that request
and the server does the processing so
that could be anything and in our cases
this is generally a web application like
flask or Django and then it returns a
response okay so I may be talking a bit
about what HTTP is and a bit of the
characteristics behind it so you can
sort of understand where HTTP and
WebSockets it relative to each other so
HTTP stands for hypertext Transfer
Protocol and it's a stateless protocol
which means after the initial request is
done that's it the the channel between
the client and server is completely lost
after this initial request right and so
I like to think of it as flipping a coin
you flip a coin once and you get your
result heads or tails and if you flip it
again
that result doesn't have anything to do
with the previous result right so the
connection is completely lost after that
initial request in the HTTP model
clients who are requesting data have to
specify an action so that's either a get
post put or delete this just tells the
server what they want to do so we get
request is retrieving some data a post
request is making something new on the
server a put request is replacing
something if it does exist we like it a
resource and a server or creating a new
one and the delete one is deleting it
resource on the server and these things
these methods and characteristics are
all put into a thing called a header
which is sent over the web to tell the
server what it wants it to do right and
the server also responds with this
header so I'm just going to quickly give
you a quick example of a basic HTTP
requests and I'm just going to show you
how you could find these headers and
look at what these things look like so
if you open up any web page like my
awesome web page here if you open up the
inspect tools and go into the network's
tab and then you can have a look down
here at all the requests you've made to
the server and if you can click on that
you can look in greater detail at what
the request is actually doing so
in a general sense you have all of the
chrome that does this nicely and it sort
of gets the data that you will probably
want to look at at the top and then it
gives you more detail beneath right and
so you can view the URL which you might
want to request so I've requested that
URL and I specified that I wanted to get
that webpage and then the server
responded with a 200 ok response which
means that my response was valid and it
returned this data so you can also look
in greater detail into the request and
the response headers down here by this
clicking view source and you can look at
exactly what headers were sent up in the
web now a lot of you who have done web
work probably you have interface with
this but I thought I might start off and
show you exactly where you should be
looking for this sort of data now
there's a couple other tabs which might
be useful when inspecting this sort of
stuff like the response tab so you can
see that the server responded with a
HTML page and all my browser's done has
loaded that page and then you have a
timing page which also shows you how
long it took to download all the data
for this page cool so in 2005 we
realized that that model wasn't really
what we wanted we wanted the web to be
able to do more than just respond with
some data ok and so we invented this
technology known as Ajax which stands
for asynchronous JavaScript and XML ok
and so what this allowed us to do is a
synchronously send data to the server
after the initial request so as you can
see with the model the client sends the
initial request for the HTML page it
gets responded with that and then it can
continue to make requests after that and
that did a lot of cool things for us so
we could do a whole range of new things
with that and I'm gonna show you another
quick example just to sort of stick with
that explain an example type thing so
you guys can get used to looking at
headers in the inspect tab so this is
just a basic page which where you click
the button and it makes an ajax request
to an api and the API responds with some
data so if I click this you'll see I'll
make a request I'll just sort of make
the headers tab a little bit smaller and
so what I've done here is just print it
what the request is so I did a get
method to this URL and I went to that
API okay and then that responded with a
greeting just as arbitrary greeting
which I created and this is great right
so we could do these things now where we
do the initial request and then we can
get more data from the server so if we
want to grab information we can just ask
the server for it and it's a really cool
thing we don't have to refresh the page
and we can do a whole lot of things but
what happens when you want to do
something which is a bit more real-time
okay what if I've got something like a
feed or a Facebook feed or a chat
application right where I want users to
be able to instantly in real time be
able to talk to each other okay
imagine if say a Facebook wall or a chat
requires you to press get all posts to
see the posts of your friends you you
wouldn't want to be able to sit there
the whole time
pressing get all posts the whole day
looking for new things I'm sorry but you
get the point right you don't want to
sit there the whole day pressing get all
posts but if you did it I guess it would
work and this this model could work for
certain applications but for stuff that
we want to be real-time it's not the
ideal thing and so ideally what we want
is a model where you can make a request
and get a response for the initial page
and then if the server happens to have
some new data in its events it can send
that data back down to me as you can see
you sort of buy the model it shows when
there's any new data it can send it down
right so in the case of a chat
application if I'm sending a message to
a group chat with all my friends the
server will get that message and then
about okay I've got this message let me
send it to all the people that want to
know about that message and if they're
connected to this the server can then
send that message to everyone is
connected so that's what WebSockets does
right
WebSockets is built to solve that
inherit prom
with HTTP and to develop that dual
channel right so what WebSockets does is
it defines this fully duplex
bi-directional communication channel
between the client and server I know
that's a whole lot of jargon but pretty
much it means that the client and the
server can talk in real time without
having to continuously make requests so
what it does is it if you want to do
WebSockets over the web
you send a header to the server saying
okay I want to upgrade from HTTP to
WebSockets and it uses that same TCP
connection that it originally
established loading the page and the
server's like ok let's upgrade
once this upgrade is done those two the
client server can continuously send data
back and forth with each other
without the overhead which HTTP might
bring with it and we never talk a bit a
bit about the performance benefits you
can have by removing headers from
requests so essentially one of the great
things about it is it's really easy to
implement and we'll get into some of the
details with that soon and it
standardized and it's been standardized
for quite a while so I don't understand
why people aren't really implementing it
more than they are and as the last point
says there the headers are only sent
once so in that initial handshake where
the server and the client agree to
upgrade to WebSockets that's the only
headers that are sent the rest is just
sending data back and forth and so you
don't have that overhead when sending
data so I'm going to sort of go over a
brief example again with that same feed
idea feel free to go on this if you want
and we can try crash my server and so
I'm gonna sort of show you how you can
inspect them and sort of see what a
WebSocket looks like so if you want you
can again feel free to go on there and
post a message so I could be like okay
my name is Dion and I could be like hey
I can make that post okay and so what's
happening here is I've made the initial
request to the server we've upgraded our
connection I've sent my message
and the service saved that message to
some database on the side and then it
sent that message out to anyone that's
connected okay and if we look at the
WebSockets headers which you can find by
going in this little tab you can see
this initial header so I'll just quickly
drag that open it's not okay so you see
the initial headers which happened with
that upgrade connection so you can see
the status code arm from the server was
okay we're gonna switch protocols to
WebSockets and so if you want to look
further into please be reasonable you
don't see a drop tables okay so if you
want to look more into what's actually
going on behind the scenes you can go
into this little tab called the frames
tab and you can see everything which is
happening behind the scenes so you can
see in my case all that's happening for
me is I've been I've upgraded my
connection to WebSockets and now all I'm
doing is receiving that data from the
server so when you guys are making those
posts it's going up into the server
saving them to the database and then
sending them back to me and you can see
that by looking at these here right so
you can see exactly what the event was
so I've made an event on my client
saying add to wall which does what it
says and it just adds that text to the
wall and you can see the the data that
came with it right so you have the
username of the person that sent it and
the message that came with it as well
and this probably isn't the best
implementation of it but it sort of just
defines it defines that that connection
okay so we'll go away I also do
apologize in advance for in creating all
the curly braces in my slides I didn't
realize until afterwards I just did it
sort of as an aesthetic thing and I was
like well I'm actually presenting this
to a bunch of Python people they
probably know that anyway so a lot of
people criticize WebSockets for its
browser support and we can now go ahead
and say that that is sort of a myth
because WebSockets is widely supported
now in all of the latest versions of the
browsers including IE which is good yes
if you still support that and if you
want to defer the reading and find these
sorts of things for other things I'd
urge you to go to this website can I use
com most web developers who've done any
front-end stuff would probably interface
with that but it's just a nice little
way of seeing if you can use it okay so
I mentioned earlier that we're gonna be
talking about other technologies used to
achieve quite similar real time goals to
what web sockets does and you may have
heard of these technologies before and
I'm not trying to decreed 't them
because they still are used today but
I'm saying web sockets can do all this
but it's an all standard way okay so
there are these two things called
polling and long polling
okay so polling is sending an ajax
request any X number of seconds so I
could tell my my client every five
seconds make a request to the server for
some new data now my work actually does
something like this right and it's not
probably the best way to do things but
it does work so you will get some sense
of real-time I guess because you will be
every X amount of seconds and it's sort
of a workaround to not having to use
that WebSockets and it should be used
sometimes when you only want to be
receiving data on intervals we also came
up with another way of doing this called
long polling now this is still I think
widely used today from what I can see
and if you look at a lot of applications
where you'd expect
WebSockets to be used like for example a
chat you'll often see that you won't be
able to inspect any WebSocket headers
and that's because people still do use
this long polling technique you might
have also heard this referred to as
comment programming but essentially what
it does is it makes a request to the
server and it tells us server not to
close that request until it has any new
data so it keeps that connection open
until the server find something to give
it and then after it gives it back the
clients just like okay I'm gonna send
you another request to do the same thing
and by doing that you sort of achieve
that goal of having dual connection
between a client and a server and there
are upsides to it and downsides to it
and we'll get onto that quite soon
another way of doing it is called server
events or server sent events sorry and
it uses this thing called the event
source API to send events from the
server and it's not truly bi-directional
because it's really based from the
server saying it to the client not an
interaction between the two of them and
that's sort of the distinction between
them and web sockets where web sockets
expects both the client and server to
continuously communicate this expects
the client to sometimes communicate with
a server but mainly for it to be server
data being sent back and so this
generally requires an event loop or
asynchronous server and one of the
downsides is you don't have that binary
message capability which you will
receive with WebSockets which supports
binary data and one of the main upsides
of this method and I guess is the
arguable thing you might want to
consider when choosing to user web
sockets or not is using this method
allows you to coexist with existing
technologies and when I say that I'm
saying it works well with rest api's and
with things like oh all right so
existing technologies which is that that
model now WebSockets can't really
interface with them properly and there's
a bit of an issue trying to request from
an API using WebSockets so you've got to
kind of consider if you want to be using
those sorts of technologies and if it's
worth the trade-off now the browser
support for service and events isn't as
good as WebSockets which is funny it's
pretty much everything except for
Internet Explorer but it that can also
be polyfilled so I guess it's arguable
that you can pretty much use WebSockets
or these in replace of each other the
intended use case of WebSockets this is
sort of a topic which is I guess
controversial so I don't want to make my
opinion change this but one of the
things I want to get clear to you guys
is WebSockets is not a complete
replacement for HTTP right WebSockets is
an upgrade we saw earlier with the
headers it's it's not a replacement for
the HTTP model but it's more an upgrade
for that channel so you can't just
replace HTTP two users because HTTP
provides you a number of benefits which
you won't receive with just native
WebSockets like for example as mentioned
in the slide automatic caching and you
can communicate with those other
technologies like rest and auth and one
of the things that's often another
critical point about WebSockets is load
balancing the server's is often quite
hard with the WebSocket protocol and it
makes the whole implementation of
deployment a little bit more complicated
than just doing HTTP server and so the
intended use case for WebSockets is
generally things where you need that
full duplex client-server interaction so
it's things where you're doing things in
real time like creating maybe a game on
the web chatting applications where
you've constantly got that interaction
anything which needs that low latency
real time connection over the web ok so
we're gonna get into some of the clients
which are used to interface with
WebSockets so these are the things which
you use to talk to a server and the
server either upgrades or doesn't
upgrade with you and I'll get into what
that means in a second
so these clients are built in a lot of
different languages including Python
which is an upside and even micro-pay an
Arduino half of them which is kind of
cool so if you're into a sort of things
you can use WebSockets which is awesome
so if you want to control any IOT
devices you can create that WebSocket
connection with a web browser so for
example if I wanted to interface with
one of my IRT devices let's say some
kind of robot or something I could
control it using my web browser with a
WebSocket connection and so clients
which interface with WebSockets aren't
necessarily web browsers like we'd
expect but the most popular
implementation of these clients are
built in JavaScript and are used as web
clients and obviously they require the
server to be able to interface with
WebSockets if a client tries to request
an upgrade with a server that doesn't
support it it'll obviously respond with
an error and you won't get that upgrade
and if you want to read more into sort
of clients and looking for the right one
that you might want to use for in your
projects I'd consider looking at socket
IO which I'm gonna go into a lot more
depth in a second and looking into just
some of the WebSocket libraries just by
doing a simple google search for a
WebSocket client and if obviously you
guys are Python people so I'd assume
you'd be looking for things in Python
and those do exist so for this example
I'm gonna be showing you the native
WebSocket support which is in JavaScript
I'm gonna show you a bit of code sort of
work through how quite easy it is to
create a client which can interface with
a WebSocket server so in this example we
start off with the initial socket
connection which is just a new WebSocket
object and again I'm sorry for pushing
JavaScript on you guys I know you're not
here for this you give this this new
WebSocket connection and you define AWS
route so for this example I'm connecting
to my local host and then you have to
define a couple of functions so the this
socket object has a non open event which
means once the protocol has been swapped
and upgraded to WebSockets this function
it's called right and so in the example
that I've got up on the screen it's just
a lambda way of dealing with that so for
example in my example I open that
connection
and then I send using socket sent I send
the string PyCon au up to the server and
then when the server sends something
back to me the socket on message is
called iris realize I don't have too
much time
so socket IO is another thing I want to
also mention and it's sort of the main
thing I want to push it you guys to use
this is a nicer way of interfacing with
WebSockets service because it's sort of
like a jQuery to JavaScript right so
it's sort of like this this library that
takes the native WebSockets and makes a
lot nicer and easier to use right and so
it includes things like Auto
reconnection and fall backs so say a
server and a client don't agree on the
handshake what it does is it uses a
fallback mechanism to use long polling
instead which is quite good if you want
to support older browsers and it gives
you that ability to do that it also as
native WebSockets does handles
disconnection in connection and it gives
this ability to create these things
called main spaces which is sort of like
a group of clients which is so they can
talk to and so a socket IO client side
code is quite similar to what you saw
before you create that initial
connection and you give it the name
space as one of the parameters to the
URL you have a connect event and you can
also send events to custom-made events
right so the native web sockets can only
send events to and a message event on
the server whereas this I can define
custom events to do that and I'm gonna
skip over this slide because I'm slowly
running out of time but there's a lot of
support for Python servers which do do
this and I'm gonna be using flask for a
lot of my examples which we should
hopefully fly through but there's a lot
of different limitations for using
socket IO and it's really really quite
easy so you create a flask application
most of you might have used flasks if
you'd ever done any web stuff with
Python but it's as easy as wrapping the
app with the provided socket object and
then creating a route which takes in a
custom event name like for example my
sockets sorry this isn't actually an
example for native web sockets so this
is where you're using that native
connection and then socket IO is where
you can do custom events and so this
namespace allows me to address a group
of people let's say the namespace PyCon
so I get all the people to connect to
this namespace Python and then I can
send messages back and forth to anyone
that's connected to that PyCon namespace
which is really quite cool for managing
groups of people so let's say you've got
chat groups you can use this namespace
to achieve that and also I came before
the performance comparison between
WebSockets and just HTTP is quite big so
HTTP requests they always send that
header whereas WebSockets don't so after
that initial connections done every
other request is only framed by a two
byte header frame I think it's called a
frame and it it's not as heavy as the
multiple kilobytes which a HTTP request
might have but then there's also that
socket IO idea from before also does
contribute to adding latency to that
WebSockets but it's not as much as HTTP
might I'm gonna quickly go to a speed
test if I can this is just on my
localhost and what it does is I enter a
number of requests I want it to perform
and it just does that so I just send in
a basic string to either my WebSocket
endpoint or my API endpoint and you'll
see how much quicker
WebSockets is in comparison to Ajax this
isn't actually hosted on the on the web
because I wanted to take latency out of
it out of the equation but you can see
it looks a bit small here cuz it's in
milliseconds but you can imagine having
a thousand hundreds of thousands of
users connected to
a connection all doing these requests
you can see how that can quickly get
quite expensive now I was going to do a
live demo but I'm quickly at a time I'm
just gonna quickly touch on deploying
these WebSockets and so synchronous
servers don't generally have support for
this so we have to use libraries such as
event let and G event to monkey patch
some of the standard libraries in Python
so synchronous just means that it it
uses blocking functions and using these
libraries unblocks it I'll go into more
detail if anyone's to know about
deploying it afterwards because I think
I've literally got a minute
but deploying WebSockets does add that
little extra layer of complexity and
doing them with asynchronous servers
makes your life a lot easier and it's
sort of the point I wanted to get across
so unfortunately I'm gonna have to wrap
up early but if you do want to talk more
about this feel free to find me outside
I'll probably be loitering around for a
little bit and thank you for coming
[Music]
Thank You Dion as you can see is very
enthusiastic about it so I'm sure he'll
answer your questions later on